We are going to try and do an experiment today.
It is called
the ‘gallium beating heart’. So it is
quite a cool experiment,
you take some molten gallium and then you
submerge it or
you put it underneath a layer of sulphuric
acid. The sulphuric
acid reacts with the gallium to form gallium
sulphate and it
changes the surface tension, so it all pulls
up into a ball and
then relaxes and there is this really neat
oscillating reaction
where you get sulphate on the surface or no
sulphate on the
surface. So you see big changes in surface
tension and the
piece of gallium is seen to beat like a heart
so we thought we
would try that today with a bit of gallium
which I am trying to
melt in my hand right now.
Many years ago, a professor bet me a hundred
pounds, when
a hundred pounds was a lot of money, that
the melting point
of gallium was lower than that of caesium
and I said it was
the other way round, but I was not courageous
enough to
take up the bet or now I would be rich.
So this is a small nugget of gallium and as
you can see if I
tap it on the hot plate it is real metal so
now we are going to
try and melt it, hopefully in my hand.
In my first video about gallium, I said that
it was not a very
interesting element with not much, many applications
and we
have had emails from people who were outraged.
There is
one email from a gentleman in America whose
company
makes tonnes of gallium salts that have quite
important
applications and of course gallium is particularly
important in
new generation of compounds, so-called semi-conductors,
that are used in the electronics industry.
So if I stand and hold it for long enough,
in theory, the
temperature should come from my hand, the
heat should
come from my hand, so it should melt the gallium
and then
eventually we should have a small amount of
liquid. So
gallium, you can form an amalgam with this
material, with all
sorts of different materials like indium and
tin. And in fact
indium, tin and gallium is used as the material
inside many,
many thermometers which are used in the medical
industry
because it is not as toxic as mercury which
was traditionally
used. You may have heard of Mendeleev. He
was the guy that
sort of conceived or brought together the
periodic table and
at the time that he did this at about 1870,
gallium hadn’t
been discovered, so he predicted its chemical
and physical
properties and he called it eka-aluminium,
approximately 5
years after that it was found using a spectroscope.
So now
we see it is melted, it looks just like a
little ball of mercury
rolling around on my hand. You can see the
thick skin that
has developed the surface tension causing
it to form such a
beautiful bulb. We are going to take out our
molten gallium
and we are going to put it under a layer of
dilute sulphuric
acid, about the same strength as battery acid,
so now we are
going to make the acid. And to do that we
are going to dilute
concentrated sulphuric acid with water. Now
it is always
important to remember that when you dilute
acid you always
put acid into water because the reaction can
be exothermic
and we want to dissipate the heat in the water
so that it does
not squirt up on our faces. The water was
room temperature,
but if I hold the measuring cylinder here
it is actually very
hot, it is maybe 40, 50, 60oC. So now before
we do our
experiment we have got to allow it to cool.
We do that by
simply running cold water outside the tube.
So this is the gallium that we melted on our
hand, now let’s
see what happens when we add the sulphuric
acid. Wow, did
you see that?
I did. What happened?
So the shape of the ball or the lump of gallium
has changed,
because we’ve changed it surface properties,
we’ve
made gallium sulphate on the surface. The
surface tension
has got higher and it has pulled up into a
nice ball, ok. So
that’s the first step of the beating heart.
What we’ve seen is
the gallium which was relaxed flat on the
surface has pulled
up really quite sharply and that is the first
stage, or the in-
beat of the heart, now we’ve got to make
the heart relax. So
what we are going to do is use dichromate.
Dichromate is a
fantastic oxidant and we are going to put
a small amount of it
in and see what happens.
So gallium, I realise now is named after France.
It was
discovered by a Frenchman and its name comes
from the old
name for France, Gaul.
So what we are doing in this experiment, we
are changing the
surface tension of the gallium, so these are
the forces that
hold the liquid into a ball or allow it to
wet and flatten on the
surface. So when the gallium is naked, ok?
It’s actually quite
flat and it wets the surface. But when we
put it under
sulphuric acid we form gallium sulphate on
the surface, this
increases the surface tension and then pulls
the gallium so it
is in a nice proud ball. What we then do is
we dribble a small
amount of dichromate solution in, which removes
the
sulphate from the surface and allows the gallium
to go flat,
and if we add the required amount of dichromate
to the
amount of acid then we can get the ball to
flatten and come
back up, flatten and come back up, so it looks
like a beating
heart.
At the moment we are really quite excited
at Nottingham
because Steve Liddle, my periodic videos colleague,
has made
a new compound in which he has got an atom
of uranium to
bond to an atom of gallium and this is exciting
because this is
the first time that chemists have ever seen
a bond between
these two atoms.
It sort of turns a terracottery colour, it
is really a deep orangey
brown, it is a bit like brick dust actually.
Of course they are not naked uranium and naked
gallium but
each of them have other things bonded to them
but it is the
first time that anybody has seen a gallium-uranium
bond.
It was one of those great moments you know,
being a
chemist is like being on a rollercoaster,
you have some days
when you wonder why am I doing this? And you
have
fantastic days where you totally remember
why you are doing
this. Because it is to be the first, to be
the first person who
has ever made this particular, you know filling
the gap,
whatever it is. It is a real thrill when you
are the first person
to make a compound that does not exist out
in the galaxy
and space, it has never existed on our planet
before but now
we have made it for the first time. That’s
a really good thing
to do
We are really very excited! A new union has
been formed
within the periodic table and it has been
done here at
Nottingham.